well I'm sure you've heard quite a bit
about Alexandria okay zo Cortez recently
probably more than probably more than
you probably way too much you've heard
way too much about her and she's right
now riding a wave of well she's riding
two waves the first wave is a wave of
attention from conservatives like myself
like the attention that I'm giving her
right now as we speak
and that's the way you'll notice that it
goes like this a lot like that the two
sides conservatives liberals they kind
of pick out stars for each other
because the star on one side is going to
be the person that the other side has
decided to pay a lot of attention to so
conservatives did that with David hog
now they're doing that with Alexandra
okay so Cortes it's it's you know I'd
say 95 percent easily of the coverage
that I've heard about this woman has
come from conservatives the same thing
with david hog and you know and you
could make the argument that donald
trump is it is a probably the prime
example of that on on the right side of
spectrum but anyway so she's got that
wave and then she's also got the wave of
socialist enthusiasm among the younger
generations and that's why she's caught
on because she's a democratic socialist
the fact that young people are so
attracted to socialism is I think a
topic worth inspecting especially
because many people have inspected it
and talked about and analyzed it and I
just I think that the analysis and the
conclusions that are drawn are often
very very wrong now different surveys
give you different figures but they all
seem to agree that around half of all
Millennials at this point find socialism
appealing on some level which is which
is really concerned that's I mean that's
a lot a half is a lot okay and according
to a recent survey that I read one in 10
Millennials believe that Joseph Stalin
who killed 20 million people
as a conservative estimate was a hero
one in ten again that is that that's
that's an enormous figure for people to
admire Joseph Stalin and then much
higher numbers admire other characters
like the killer and terrorist Che
Guevara and others so how do we explain
this affinity for socialism among and
communism among America's youth well I
don't think it's that hard to understand
really I think the explanation is is
really pretty simple it's kind of a
matter of arithmetic it's it's sort of a
a mathematical equation and the equation
goes like this okay it's failed
parenting plus fail plus failed
education system equals socialist that's
how you make socialist and so let's talk
about parents first of all
it's the it's the job of a parent to
raise their children into independent
and self-sufficient adults and so
someone a newly minted adult someone
who's just become an adult should they
should want nothing more than to break
out of the protective cocoon of
childhood and and go out into the world
untethered free able to do whatever they
want energy ambition boldness vision
these are the things these are the marks
of youth or at least that used to be it
used to be the primary characteristics
of youth but what we find today is that
many young people are they have no
desire to leave the cocoon at all they
they or else they they desire to leave
one cocoon and then promptly enter into
another one so they want to leave the
cocoon of the home and their parents and
then they want to go into the cocoon of
the welfare state the nanny state
they want daddy in Washington to
supplant daddy at home that's what
they're looking for and it cannot be
overstated just how unnatural this is
and you see it reflected a lot in a lot
of ways I think one symptom of this is
you read these reports now about how
young people teenagers are getting their
drivers licenses at later and later ages
they're waiting I think on average now
what I read is that what I don't know if
it's on average but there's a great many
of the teenagers who now they don't get
there they don't get their driver's
license until after they turn 18 until
after they graduate high school and
there are several reasons for that one
one is just the kids are at home on on
the internet all the time or playing
video games so they feel like there's no
need to drive but that's related to this
lack of
this lack of energy and and boldness and
one I remember when I was a kid I wanted
nothing more than to get my driver's
license just so I could leave and go I
didn't even care where I went to I
remember the firt when I got my driver's
license the first place I went I went to
uh I went to Rite Aid pharmacy and I got
like a pack of gum or something but it
didn't matter right because I I I was
able to go myself
it's one of the great moments of my life
is that I was able to go myself to a
store and get something and I was
amazing and that again used to be a
common thing among young people's that
you you wanted the license you could get
out on the highway be on your own have
freedom and it seems like kids
increasingly don't really desire that
they're fine being at home with their
parents and having no freedom and
depending on I guess they have developed
this they've gotten used to dependence
and they have no desire to break free
from it and that is a very concerning
sign I think and this is what lies at
the at the root of the socialist
inclination in the younger generations
it's it's more than anything it's a
failure of it's a it's a it is a failure
of personal formation of moral formation
and I don't think it's fair to blame
this entirely on parents I mean it is
theoretically possible that you could
have a kid who turns into a socialist
even though he had great parents seems
unlikely it could happen but there is a
link that's obviously hard to ignore
that's parent then you have the
education system and the education
system has contributed enormous Lee to
this problem because you only need to
have a really basic knowledge of of
recent world history we're not even
going back we're not talking about
ancient Rome okay
we're not going back hundreds of years
not going back centuries you simply need
to have an understanding of what has
happened in the world over the last
century
if you have that understanding then
there is no way that socialism and
communism would seem appealing to you
these these regimes murdered 100 million
people if not more over the course of a
century leaving many millions more
starving destitute the 20th century was
the deadliest and most miserable 10
decades in human history by far without
any competition for the title by the way
and this is not exclusively but largely
thanks to the systems of government that
now half of my generation want to
establish here
and so that is an incredible amount of
ignorance
that that you you must place at the feet
of the school system do you think the
average socialist millennial even
realizes that when he says Nazi he's
referring to the National Socialist
German Workers Party but do you think
you understand said but Nazis are
National Socialists I assume he doesn't
know but but how could that be pi how
could you make it through thirteen years
of formal schooling or seventeen years
including college or even more than that
and then come away still ignorant of the
fundamental facts of recent history how
is that possible
it's almost impressive you you almost
have to be impressed with how
ineffective our school system is because
you would think that all you have to do
is just throw kids into an environment
and have a few books around and if
they're in that environment for thirteen
to seventeen years they're they're
inevitably going to absorb some
information you think you wouldn't be
able to stop them but our school system
has somehow managed to prevent kids from
developing even the basic fundamental
understandings of history it is an
incredible thing and again we're not
talking about events from ancient times
we're talking about events that many
people walking the earth now today
actually lived through and are still
living through in places like Venezuela
yet the Democrat Party has managed to
tap into this very large supply of
supposedly educated people who possess
almost no functional knowledge
whatsoever at least they possess no
functional knowledge when it comes to
history and I would submit when it comes
to many other subjects as well so with
that in mind how can we call our
education system anything other than a
cataclysmic disaster
that it has produced ignorance and
intellectual laziness and idiocy on a on
a on an unprecedented scale and it has
somehow managed this feat at precisely
the moment when knowledge and
information have never been more readily
available
this is this is what's happened I know
people don't like it when I what I blame
the education system and I always hear
from teachers and who say I I'm yeah I'm
I care about my kids I'm educating my
kids I'm not I know that there are good
teachers out there I don't deny that but
but and if you're a good teacher then
good for you because you are working
against the tide
you've got everything stacked against
you and at the end of the day even if
you're the best teacher in the world in
most high school environments you're
only gonna have your kid for the kids
any particular kid you're only gonna
have for 45 minutes a day if not like 45
minutes a week or every couple or ever
you know a couple of times every week
and there's it's there's only so much
you can do in that time
I
think
even if you're in the system and you
work for the system you can't deny I
mean look look around you
at the incredible ignorant that people
are displaying and remember we are this
is ignorance in a time when there is no
excuse for it at all
because as I pointed out many times
before we all carry around in our
pockets
all of the knowledge that you could
possibly need it's all here
and then in school it's supposed to be
presented to you in a in a in a in a
kind of systematic way that you can
absorb and understand
so the the rise of socialism is an
enormous failure on the part of schools
and the part of parents the crop of the
young crop has been I guess you could
say fertilized by bad education bad
parenting and now it's really no trouble
for socialists to just kind of come
along and pick the fruits
and there's no real way to stop them
either unless we make drastic changes to
our homes and and to our schools
so if you're wondering why people are
socialist that's why it's not because
the socialist program is really that
appealing
it's only a peon well I should say it is
appealing to ignorant people who have
not been properly formed personally and
morally that's who it's appealing to but
to rational intelligent people who have
been educated and who have been properly
formed as human beings it isn't it is
the most unappealing thing in the world
especially at this point now that we
have a hundred years of history we can
look back and see all the bloodshed
misery and death and say wow yeah no
thanks
Alexandria
is is having a wonderful time tapping
into that
all right we're
off there but thanks for watching thanks
listen anybody have a great weekend and
I'll talk to you next week